oh we're back with the lovely and
talented Chloe Bailey
because we're about to play a trivia
game with the twist it's called who knew
don't spew
[Music]
yay all right hi Rossi you are the
leader with the most take it away I'm
going to tell you how this is going to
work I'm going to ask you trivia
questions you each have to answer at the
same time using these white boards all
right for every wrong answer you get you
have to take a step closer to this box
and whoever reaches the last Circle has
to eat whatever is under it and I
promise Drew Chloe whatever's under
there is your worst nightmare oh God all
right my heart's pounding are you ready
to see what you'll have to eat if you're
the first one to get to the Box let's
reveal it
thank you
[Applause]
Drew Barrymore how do you feel about
lamb
I've never been able to even chew it let
alone swallow it well we have we have
them lamb meatballs for you
oh and Miss Bailey can I ask you what is
one of your least favorite foods
avocados yep which is why we have tons
of avocado and guacamole for you so how
are you feeling now my heart's pounding
and I'm getting nervous and my mouth is
watering but not in a good way okay
up into position right out here behind
this first dot behind it behind it okay
okay question number one you're gonna
write the answer down on the Whiteboard
what was the name of Beyonce's solo
debut album
write it down if you get it right you
can stay put if you get it wrong you
gotta walk towards your worst nightmare
let's reveal your answers what was
Beyonce's first solo debut album called
reveal your answers
at the same time you say Dangerously in
Love you say Beyonce the answer is
Dangerously in Love
[Applause]
you can stay quickly but Drew you take
that step we're right there on that
first one you're right right there I'm
so happy for you I mean it
okay question number two
what reptile has the longest lifespan
but you're just a few steps away from a
giant platter of lamb meatballs with
your name on it let's reveal what is the
uh the reptile with the longest lifespan
you say alligator you say snake the
answer is not either of those it's a
giant tortoise which means you each are
taking a step forward you come to the
first dot Drew you go to the second one
okay can you smell the lamb meatballs
from that dog I'm not craving right now
question number three which actor voiced
both Darth Vader and the Lion King's
Mufasa
write the answer down on your whiteboard
I feel the the audience knows and
they're being real good not yelling it
out reveal your answers one two three
two says James Earl Jones that's correct
you drew apart Chloe look at what Chloe
wrote look just a heart
blank but you know who the person is but
you get nervous so you can't speak yeah
so step on that second dot that was your
second incorrect answer so you and Joe
are now tied I love you and I'm sorry
here is your next question how many
Harry Potter books are there
[Music]
oh your answer came real fast
write your answers down and let's reveal
them oh oh on three one two three
you each say eight and the answer is
seven
oh your Eight's gonna take one step
closer
so guess what we're walking to our you
both lost which means we get a double
tasting
all right
maybe if you dip it in the guacamole it
won't taste so bad
here's a big giant spoon for you I gotta
fill up the whole spoon you do whatever
you want and there's a fork for your
meatballs Drew everyone uh what do you
think yeah hold my hand
s I'm so sorry let's count them in three
two one
all right
I can't I can't
oh my gosh let's give them a big round
of applause
it takes real meatballs to do that
thank you so much Chloe Bailey thank you
so much praise this is available to
stream right now on peacock TV we'll be
right back with a surprise giveaway for
our entire audience
[Music]